have you taken on the pride and
responsibility of being the strongest
most selfless class in destiny - well
good here are some tips to help you
succeed and feel like a total boss
whether you're with a bi team or playing
solo and whether you're just starting
out or optimizing your endgame if you
are only just starting out we've got
plenty of beginners guides to class
skills and just about everything else on
gamespot and if you enjoyed this vid and
see more stuff like it you like destiny
videos right all right first up be
proactive in supporting your allies the
Titans class ability which activate by
holding Crouch creates a wall of cover
which is hands-down the most useful
skill to help a team out during a
firefight so with the class ability you
have two versions to pick from the first
one is rallying barricade which creates
a chest high wall that a few people can
fit behind once you're crouched under it
you can pop out and fire over the wall
by aiming down sights once you release
your left trigger and go back down your
gun will instantly reload this is a
really great tool to use when you're
taking on large groups of relatively
weak enemies like acolytes or dregs
since you can basically fire non-stop
that said being able to instantly reload
power weapons against the elite enemies
is pretty useful - imagine firing one
shot rocket launchers like a
semi-automatic but since most bosses
tend to dance around a lot you might
have to measure up the situation first
so you don't completely waste it
towering barricade is the other option
and this one's great to pull out in
really dicey situations like strikes and
nightfalls this barricade is much larger
and can block big splash damage if there
isn't much safe cover around towering
barricade is also good for protecting
capture point and crucible and it'll
also damage an enemy team that runs
through it next up every good fire team
needs ward of dawn the central is good
of the protected trait tree is one you
should be using if you're in a fighting
that needs help with survival especially
in night falls and raids with it you get
water dawn and the game's best defensive
tool it's a shield urn that blocks all
incoming damage and gives you increased
resistance while you're in it it uses
your super of course but it's a great
last-ditch to stop your teammates from
dying or just give everyone a breather
it's also really good for setting up a
safe zone around downed allies which
will let you revive them in relative
safety in PvP
what if Dawn is a valuable tool for
making sure you and your allies can hold
we'll protect point but you'll likely
only get one you said a bit per match so
make it count
all right here's the most important
Titan - you got to get amongst it you
got a punch everything if you and your
fireteam find yourselves in slightly
more forgiving scenarios you'll learn
that the Titans offense can sometimes be
the best defense if your team is
confident enough to fight behind enemy
lines the melee skills and the Sentinels
code of the protected tree are really
advantageous to you and your team get
the ability to both heal and Grant
burnished shields to yourself and me by
allies every time you kill something
with a charged melee attack if you save
it in your time it right you can
basically give everyone a second life
the sunbreakers subclass has similar
buffs whether the fire Forge gives your
charged melee kill the ability to grant
bonus movement and reload speed but
obviously these traits are more useful
when you're fighting at mid-range
distance it's worth changing enough if
you know what kind of situations you're
going to be getting yourself in the
offense is the best defense thing
applies to solid play - Titans can tank
more damage than other classes and each
Titan subclass has a trait tree that
focuses on boosting offensive potential
if you don't have any squishy hunters of
warlocks the babysit flip over to one of
the more offensive trees to kill more
things more quickly this is also
something to consider if you're in a
fireteam with another Titan filling the
support role already the Sentinels code
of the aggressive tree gives you an
additional throw of The Sentinel shield
super and gives you a trait that
decreases your supercooled down when you
kill enemies surrounded by other enemies
again in there be what a Titan should be
and keep that super up as much as you
can the strikers Kurt of the Earthshaker
tree helps boost your area of effect
damage potential with the fists of havoc
super leaving damaging fields of our
energy after you perform ground pounds
it'll also give you an extra grenade
charge and your pulse and lightning
grenades additional pulses all of these
traits are a huge boon when facing big
groups of clumped up enemies that charge
you all the time when you need to create
treacherous ground just soften up
someone the sunbreakers co2 the fire
forged tree really makes the hammer of
Sol supers shine it'll cause enemies hit
by it to explode the hammers to shatter
meaning throwing them into big groups
can have spectacular explosive effects
each of these subclasses also comes with
a brutal charging melee attack
does an area of effect damage with
various effects which is a very strong
opener after you sprint headfirst into a
pack of enemies in PvE or to surprise
opponents around corners in the crucible
with all that in mind
a wise Titan knows when to retreat not
punching things for a while is better
than having to restart from the
beginning of a darkness urn when all of
your abilities are on cooldown all your
guns are need reloading your health is
flashing red and you're still surrounded
by enemies get the hell out of there
catapult job is probably the most useful
jump to have equipped anytime you're not
doing any serious platforming or
traversal that's because it gives you a
faster burst of momentum when you
trigger the jump meaning you can get the
hell out of a sticky situation a little
faster in really dicey oshit moments
towering barricade is also something to
have on standby here if you haven't used
it and you know you've got to get out it
can be a good tool to block fire as you
regenerate health retreat to a second
position or if the situation is right
you can just drop it fortify your
position and give yourself a breather
while you wait for your health to
regenerate if you've got any advice that
I haven't listed here please feel free
to leave in the comments below so
everyone can benefit hopefully some of
this has been helpful to you and I wish
you all the best in your journey to
punch all the space things
if you need more destiny guides you can
obviously subscribe to GameSpot destiny
2 is gonna be here for a long time and
will be here to cover all the new events
and happenings so stay tuned